congratulations on the book a chosen
destiny you know i don't know if there
is
uh such a thing as a conventional road
to becoming wwe champion
but like something that obviously sticks
out with your story is
just that perseverance that you've had
because not very many people get to
the point where they're kind of handed
you know
the brass ring and then have it taken
away and then
they get to claw their way back up
yeah it's certainly a unique unique
journey like a lot of people tend to
work hard work their way from the bottom
uh to the top i was fortunate
and perhaps unfortunate at the same time
that when i was younger i was given a
lot of opportunity
be it in the uk when i was wrestling
there as a teenager i was always the
main event i was always
pushed as the the top prospect and i was
assigned to wwe 21
came to america was taken from our
developmental system the training system
putting straight on television in my
third week
in america the fastest ever person moved
from developmental to a major show on
a friday night smackdown or tuesday
smackdown at the time
and suddenly i was in the ring at
vincent man pointing at me
saying basically this is the future of
the company right here this
chosen one and i had to go backstage and
go
hmm this is perfectly normal i'm just
the chosen one that's my storyline and
the funny thing is even though as
big as that is and it's the first time
vince man ever did that and probably
will ever do it again
i was so used to being in a top position
i just saw it as my storyline at the
time
and that's perfectly normal i'm just
going to become world champion at 23 24
years old
and i'll be 25 time world champion the
time my career is over
didn't quite go that way i am i started
at the top and i fell
very very far not just to the bottom and
about 10 feet under the bottom i got
fired from wwe
had to overcome a lot professionally but
especially personally to work my way
back to the company and to the top of
the mountains wwe champion
what do you attribute or who do you
attribute um
you know to helping you get back to the
point where you could
you could get to where you are now like
you know you didn't spend a lot of time
in the indies after
after leaving wwe but is there a
particular point
or person that helped you get back to
where you wanted to be
uh pick a particular person i'd be my
wife 100
um you know professionally from the
second i was fired i
knew this was on me and i had to make
some big changes professionally
if i was going to succeed in this
industry and come up with a game plan
you know with my wife and i detail in
the book and started going out there and
was lucky to get a lot of opportunities
a lot of platforms to show what i could
really do as realistically when i was
released from wwe i went from
you know the guy who was saving the girl
from the tracks walking away
throwing the match behind him with the
building exploding in the background
to the comedy act like not even the
comedy psychic i was lower than the
comedy psychic when i got fired so
i had a lot of work to do to make people
believe i could be a marketable draw
in this industry and i was working my
butt off got a lot of platforms to do it
was
thankfully very successful because of
people believing in me from a
professional standpoint but behind the
scenes
um i was still tail spilling tail
spinning and you know i'd lost my mother
a few years prior
before that and that's when i went off
the deep end i was drinking all the time
i was
partying all the time i wasn't burning
the kind of both ends the whole candle
was just a light on fire
as good as things were going
professionally outside of wwe and i was
becoming the number one superstar
outside of wwe
i was ready for a crash and burn and i
took
a broken neck which i talked about in
the book
and eight weeks off i got lucky with a
broken neck it was a non-displaced
fracture i just needed time off but it
was the first time off i've had in my
life
i was signed from university i was
always told where to be what to do by
school
i was in wwe where to be what to do they
were in control of my schedule
when i was fired i was the busiest
wrestler in the world i never stopped
until it was eight weeks and it was
during that time i sat with my wife her
girlfriend at the time fiance at the
time
um and she told me one you're gonna
crash and burn if you keep this up
outside the ring as well as you're doing
professionally
two i'm gonna leave your ass because
you're an absolute liability right now
and you're never here and i'm trying to
hold the fort together you're just not
holding up your end as a partner
and i spoke to my family spoke to her
understood
that my drinking partying was not an
addiction it was just a bad habit
farm to deal with a lot of things
including my emotions
and things i hadn't dealt with like my
mother's death and i really started
trying to work through that
during that period started opening up
more and
finally cut those negatives out of my
life and
that was the big difference maker right
there once i cut those negatives out i
started opening up
i came to my emotions to my wife things
went to the next level as good as i was
doing they were 10 times better my head
was clear
my body started improving well i started
just dieting more and suddenly i found
myself back in wwe within two months
so 100 my wife was a difference maker
you know that's a nice
an important lesson for fans as well as
as a wrestling fan one of the
most heartbreaking things is seeing
people that you
um have been a fan of and that you look
up to
kind of spiral out of control and there
are so many stories
of these tragic endings to to these guys
careers
or lives and that must have been
something that you know that played on
you as well specifically at that time
yeah i mean i don't know if i thought
about it as much as other people did
on my behalf and just worried about me
and because it started off just like a
night out here and there
but at my worst it was every single
night it was oh we just have a few
drinks after the show and then it's well
it was a day off
we got it they have a few drinks but for
me it was just really how it was dealing
with a lot of my emotional baggage like
i say my mother passing was the biggest
one of all but also being fired from my
dream job i was
dealing with feelings i was not good
enough um
and just multiple things it was all
bottled up inside i talked about it in
the book how important it is
to get that out and if you hold it
inside eventually you're gonna explode
and self-destructive behavior doesn't
just affect you it affects the ones you
love and people around you and i was
really hurting people around me with my
behavior and you never know if you
watched me on a show
saw how i was doing at the time oh
drew's got it all together he's doing
fantastic he doesn't need wwe he's the
biggest superstar in the world right now
but behind closed doors i was definitely
not healthy not in a good place and
thanks to
like say a good support system
especially my wife and it's interesting
the theme of the book
the strong female leads in my life who
led me to be the guy i am today starting
with my mother then my wife
you know it took some strong women to
get this big man
back on track right on of course
you know that that first time back in
the wwe ring
were you feeling you know an amount
immense amount of pressure to sort of
get it right or was it more
the idea that you're here and now you're
you have this opportunity
to do it the way you know you could
yeah there wasn't the pressure the first
time i was there i was so
stressed um i couldn't relax
i was tense all the time i was thinking
about the next movement i had to make i
was thinking about the next word i had
to say and if you look at my eyes you
can see
i'm just not in the moment i'm just not
relaxed i'm just trying my best and
trying too hard
which is obvious to the fans this
person's not feeling it they're not
enjoying themselves so i'm not going to
be able to enjoy it with them because
they won't let me in and be part of the
moment
when i came back to the company i was a
polish performer i was
i knew who i was i knew like if you give
me a microphone i don't need a big
script i just need a general idea i can
handle my own in the microphone i know
if you put me in the ring with anybody
i'll have a good match with anybody
i'd finally grown up not just as a
person outside the ring but as a
performer in the ring
and i was excited just any opportunity
you give me now i know i'm gonna knock
it out the park or at least be
comfortable
with it because i know who i am finally
and that's been a theme for the past few
years i've been back in wwe is
a lot of stuff changes but whatever
situation you put me in i'm always going
to be drew because drew mcintyre is just
drew galloway with the volume turned up
yeah well it's funny we talked around
wrestlemania time
last year about just how unique of a
situation it was for you becoming wwe
champion
um in like the performance center right
and then come wrestlemania 37 you've got
100 thousands of people do you feel like
you were back in your element
with that crowd there giving you because
that that's something that's really an
integral part of
um the whole experience yeah like
wrestlemania 37
was wild you know with us made 36 i won
my first wwe championship in front of
nobody
and that empty performance center beat
brock lesnar and to silence
and as much as we had huge numbers on
social media it
was very strange nothing fans there see
fast forward one year
miraculously we're doing a round two in
my american hometown it's in tampa it's
back at raymond james stadium i get a
redo i'm fighting for the title again
against lashley
and we've got our fans there and we
almost got rained out like i was like
thinking to myself my jigs
every time i fight for the title
something goes wrong like last year i
fight for the title there's a worldwide
pandemic this year we're gonna get
rained out and
you know how i was convinced like we're
gonna get delayed a week at one point
and eventually i get that chance to walk
in front of the fans and
in the back of my mind i was also
thinking i wonder how they react
you know we've not had them in the
building for one year one month and one
day
at the time and i've had a lot of drew
content of a lot of drew mcintyre and a
lot of
like tv social media i've been
dominating the show i've been the
featured performer monday night raw for
a long time and
people get pretty sick pretty quick of a
lot of things in today's day and age
things move a bit fast they move on to
the new the new thing the new person
so maybe they're sick of drew i don't
know we've not had them live in the
building yet we hear them in the thunder
dome it's been positive but
how they're going to be in person maybe
they're going to boo maybe they're not
going to be as positive as i think
they're going to be or hope they're
going to be and to walk out there for
the first time and hear such a positive
response
it really took me aback of wow this is
pretty cool
i am having them here for the first time
hearing them react so positively for the
first time
having the first match myself and
lashley and shocking them with the
finish that i didn't get my big moment
for the crowd when lashley actually won
the match and uh
knocked me out with his finish which was
cool as well because i think it's part
of my story like you know chosen destiny
the book
talks about that i'm knocked down a lot
of the time it's
it's not about how many times i get
knocked down it's how many times i get
back up and
even though i didn't get my moment i
think that's just another chapter in the
book that you knock me down i get back
up i get stronger and i keep fighting
and i'm fighting for that wrestlemania
moment in front of a crowd
love that that's awesome man you know
something that's really fun to me
thinking about you and and drew mcintyre
in front of this huge crowd
how good you are on the mic how much
charisma you've got is the idea that you
said yourself you're like an introvert
kind of a homebody
right like you like being home um i'm
wondering
what is your binge watch go to like what
is drew mcintyre's
binge watch recommendation for people
when they're you know when they're
feeling the way you're feeling when you
want to be at home
mrs and i watch so many shows it's
unbelievable and we just keep powering
through them keep running out of
episodes it's driving me crazy
um she if you if everyone's not
anybody's not seen outlander
check it out obviously i'm scottish i'm
gonna push things that remind me of home
one brand very on brand yeah yeah i
didn't discover it like i've been
forced braveheart on my wife a bunch of
times she's like yes whatever
whatever it's the greatest movie ever
made completely historically accurate
don't check google don't check any
history books
but for a phenomenal movie and she's the
one who discovered outlander and i was
like you found this and just such a
great show and
uh my goodness there's been so many the
most recent one we got into was um
superman and lois on uh hbo max
and i was so angry there was only five
episodes because i just started like two
days ago and then i got into it and we
ran out of episodes right away
so that was the latest one we get into
but we've watched every show that's
the in show we've probably power drive
through it in two days
right on that's awesome and hey well
congratulations on the book
and um you know i was thinking too
another career path for you is literally
reading audio books because your voice
reading your book
is wicked it's awesome
thanks for your time man all the best i
appreciate it buddy and thank you for
checking out the audiobook as well
appreciate you having me take care
everybody